-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're
doing well tonight
and, now, if you don't mind,
we're going to get to the news.
Donald Trump's
former personal attorney
Michael Cohen
was released yesterday from his
18-month-long house arrest.
The decision is being celebrated
by everyone
from his wife to his kids.
[ As Cohen ]
Do you guys want to hear
something else Trump did?
"No!"
[ Laughter ]
He did some crazy stuff.
"We know, Dad!
[ Laughter ]
Get out of the house!"
President Biden traveled
to Nantucket today
for Thanksgiving,
but only after Jill made him
swear on the Bible --
no limericks.
[ Laughter ]
The House Committee
investigating January 6th
issued subpoenas yesterday
for several allies
of former President Trump,
including conspiracy theorist
Alex Jones
and longtime advisor
Roger Stone,
which could only mean Flap--
"Flap."
[ Laughter ]
Was his name Flattop
or Flaptop?
[ Laughter ]
I feel like it was
always unclear.
[ Laughter ]
Don't worry, this punch line
will still work.
[ Laughter ]
Which can only mean Flattop
and Little Face are next.
[ Laughter ]
Why'd you write in
the Flaptop part?
[ Laughter ]
[ Fresh laughter ]
In a new interview,
Dr. Anthony Fauci said
that vaccinated people should
"feel good and safe
about enjoying Thanksgiving
in their homes,"
while unvaccinated people should
really rely on that wishbone.
[ Laughter ]
"Grandma, I need this more
than you do."
[ Laughter ]
Port Authority officials
have projected
that over 1.4 million people
will travel through New York
and New Jersey airports
over the Thanksgiving holiday
and 1.2 million of them
will stand up
as soon as they call Group 1.
[ Laughter ]
Germany's health minister held
a press conference yesterday
to address the country's spike
in coronavirus cases
and said that Germans
will either be,
"vaccinated, recovered,
or dead by the end of winter."
Or, as it's called in Germany,
a pep talk.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Analysts are projecting that,
this year,
there will be a smaller
selection of Christmas trees
for Americans to choose from,
which explains the one
outside of 30 Rock.
[ Laughter ]
Did you think it was going
to be that little, Baze?
I thought it was supposed
to be four feet,
but I guess I don't know
the difference
between feet and inches.
[ Laughter ]
That's a real little fella.
And, finally, an Oklahoma woman
was recently kicked
out of church
after she brought cilantro
to a service
that was mistaken for marijuana,
which was a double whammy
because, "A,"
she got kicked out of her church
and, "B,"
she got ripped off
by her weed guy.
[ Laughter and applause ]
And that was a monologue,
everybody!